momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a
nuestra periodista daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches y empezamos
hablando sobre guatemala el oficialismo
dará marcha atrás a su proyecto del
presupuesto
andrés buenas noches pues como sabemos y
como vimos en el informativo el país
vivió un agitado fin de semana el
miércoles el parlamento aprobó el
proyecto de presupuesto para 2021 casi
en secreto mientras el país estaba
distraído con el huracán ya está esto
desató una multitud multitudinaria
manifestación y la quema de una parte
del parlamento pero el legislativo de
mayoría oficialista dio marcha atrás con
la finalidad de mantener la
gobernabilidad del país y la paz social
hemos acordado suspender el trámite
después del presupuesto de ingresos y
egresos del estado y del organismo
legislativo para el periodo 2021 el
descontento se originó andrés entre
otras cosas porque dentro del plan por
12 mil 900 millones de dólares los
legisladores aprobaron 65 mil dólares
para sus
comidas del año y aumentaron los aportes
para el pago de deuda pero a su vez
redujeron gastos en salud educación
derechos humanos y hasta el sistema
judicial
daniela y desde este lunes western y
unión no prestará servicios en cuba así
es andrés pues en este lunes se cerraron
las 407 sucursales que ha abierto la
empresa de transferencias más grandes
del mundo en este país durante dos
décadas esto en el marco de las más
recientes sanciones de eeuu contra su
sociedad fin simex que es controlada por
el ejército cubano para calcular el
impacto de la medida basta con saber que
alrededor de 1,6 millones de cubanos
viven en el exilio sólo en 2019 muchos
de ellos se enviaron a sus familiares
más de mil millones de dólares ahora
tendrán que buscar alternativas por
ejemplo otras agencias que cobran una
mayor comisión o podrán usar también
cripto monedas pero ya sabemos andrés
del enorme riesgo de este tipo de
transacciones que no son vigiladas por
las autoridades y ahora vamos a europa
por qué
el reloj en contra este lunes se
retomaron las conversaciones para un
acuerdo post sobre éxito siempre la
unión europea y el reino unido-
retomaron este lunes sus conversaciones
para intentar cerrar por fin a un
acuerdo sobre su futura relación una vez
se consume el presi pero hoy persisten
las mismas divergencias que cuando
empezaron a negociar que son igualdad de
condiciones pesca y resolución de
disputas futuras todo apunta a que desde
el primero de enero estos recién
divorciados tendrán que regirse por las
normas de la organización mundial del
comercio escuchamos o tienes un trato o
no tienes un trato solo para ser
absolutamente claro al respecto al final
del año el reino unido- abandona el
mercado único y la unión aduanera no hay
posibilidad de extender el periodo de
transición más allá de ese punto esa
fecha está escrita en piedra
y daniela la pandemia de coronavirus ha
afectado a la industria pesquera de eeuu
andrés un grupo de científicos
cuantificó el daño que ha causado la
pandemia en esta industria y sus
hallazgos son muy poco alentadores el
estudio publicado en la revista
especializada face and fisheries dice
que la demanda de los consumidores de
productos de mar en los restaurantes se
ha reducido en más del 70% mientras
tanto importaciones cayeron alrededor
del 37 por ciento y las exportaciones
casi un 43% esto durante los primeros
nueve meses del año en comparación con
2019 y los estados más afectados han
sido main alaska y luisiana que son los
que dependen en gran medida de este
sector y ahora vamos con los indicadores
daniela y andrew de la bolsa de nueva
york cerró en positivo por el optimismo
sobre las vacunas anti cob y también en
medio de rumores de que la ex presidenta
de la fed janet yellen será la
secretaria del tesoro de joe bites en
europa no se contagiaron de ese
optimismo aunque los descensos de hoy
fueron leves de hecho en la farmacéutica
británica atrás
estuvo entre las mayores caídas de la
jornada y américa latina cerró
mayormente en positivo
y la cifra del día pues el precio de las
vacunas anti kobe de 19 más avanzadas
hasta este momento acordado por las
farmacéuticas con los gobiernos extras
técnica de oxford que han dicho que no
obtendrán ganancias por su vacuna
cobrarán 2.5 dólares por dosis la de
facer y variante cuesta 20 dólares y la
de moderna valdría entre 15 y 25 dólares
daniela muchas gracias por traernos la
información económica en esta edición en
noticias de france 24 y ustedes muchas
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]